We're live now.
Professional.
We're so professional.
We go right into it.
It's like random.
It's because you're pink, Onigiri.
Yeah, you're orange.
Wait, you're orange, Snuffy.
Wait, you do look like Rock Lee.
Wait, what color am I?
I'm red.
Okay, I'll explain the rules for everybody here.
Welcome, ladies!
Okay, I have one person listening.
We're all having our own conversation.
Okay, all right, ladies!
I will explain the rules for all of us in chat.
Okay, I'll explain the rules to you.
I'll explain the rules to you.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, it's basically like Among Us, but like first person.
That's really it.
Who's who?
Is it Prada?
Of course it's Prada.
We should just call each other by our colors.
Oh my god, yeah!
Yeah, if none of us have names, then we won't have any prejudice.
Like, free.
You're so tired.
Yeah, yeah.
If we all call each other by colors and not know who's who, then like we can't judge each other by past mistakes.
By new mistakes?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll judge you by the color of your suit.
You're pink, I'm green.
I forgot.
All right.
You're red.
You're pink.
Okay, you're pink, I'm red.
What color am I?
All right.
You're white.
White?
Oh.
What does that mean?
I'm rolling in his grave right now.
All right, so this is basically like Among Us and Trouble in Terrorist Town mixed together.
But like the thing is, if we find the traitor and we kill them off, we don't know.
We don't know.
Because the game, we still have to complete the task.
So like we, the innocents win by completing all the tasks.
And then the traitors win by killing everybody.
You still have to finish your job.
Yeah, you still have to finish your job because the ship is still, you know, the ship is still needs to be fixed.
You're actually pointing and making me feel accused.
It's you.
Also, there's like weapons everywhere.
So like even innocent people can kill.
So we, like innocents can also kill people.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I love the TTT point where you actually have to kill your enemies.
Yeah, spell innocent backwards.
If you're innocent, spell innocent backwards.
Yeah.
You can't do that sh**.
Oh, that's very funny.
Yeah.
I use...
Have you trained your hands again, y'all?
Oh, it's F.
F F.
It's like, yeah.
Oh?
Oh yeah, yeah.
What does it tell me?
It says, Simon.
Simon says, God damn it.
Simon says...
I'll touch it until you can't anymore.
Give her a little lift.
Give it to me.
Give your bullet.
I did it!
That's so dumb!
Okay, how do you ready up?
Okay, I readied up.
You press Q, you open your tablet, and then you press Q.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, here we go.
We're so ready.
We're gonna save the world!
I believe in all of us.
I have no idea what I'm writing.
Okay.
Um...
I hope you guys will enjoy this clap.
Alright.
Alright, I'm innocent.
Oh yeah!
I can spell innocent backwards!
T-O...
Where are you?
Where even are my tasks?
I have...
If you press Q, you'll see where the stuff is.
Oh, okay.
It's yellow.
My stuff is yellow.
Oh, I have a gun!
Nothing!
No!
She's alive!
No, she's alive!
If there's a murder, they have to be dead!
No, I don't have a gun!
Look!
No gun!
My hands are up.
I really have my hands up!
I have no gun.
What do you mean?
I need to do my task, guys.
I have work to do.
I...
You have to do your task!
I'm gonna do task!
Alright, how do I do this?
Oh, another gun.
Why do they keep giving me guns?
Okay.
Where's the task?
Is it this?
Oh, is this the camera?
Oh my god, I should have read the instructions.
Okay.
Oh, vents!
What am I supposed to do in the vents?
Okay.
There are three vents.
Guys, I should have watched this tutorial before I started.
Oh, do I just have to check the vents?
What am I doing?
There's the box.
Yeah, I see the vents.
And then...
Vent here.
Okay, weapon.
Oh!
I need to grab a screwdriver!
Okay.
The fuck are the screwdrivers?
Is that the screwdriver?
Where are the screwdrivers?
How am I supposed to do my task?
Does anyone have screwdrivers?
Wait, who killed her?
Wait, who killed Pink?
Who killed Pink?
Oh!
It blew up.
Okay.
Do we just trust people when they're like, oh, that dead body?
What the fuck?
Who found this dead body?
Alright, we're just gonna leave that.
Yeah, she's always been dead.
It's just been that way.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
We're too busy.
We have to do our work, guys.
Like, we're too busy to handle the dead.
Okay, how do I do this?
Are we meant to apprehend the person who did this?
Or is it trial by combat?
I think it's just... I think we just gotta fix the ship?
That would do it.
I think... yeah, I think the ship is more important than a dead body, apparently.
You gotta find, like, batteries.
Why do you have a screwdriver?
Oh, thank you.
I actually needed that.
Thanks.
Alright, now...
Now I can fix the vent, guys.
Now I can do my job.
Wait, what?
They fixed it.
Wait, they fixed it!
The fuck was I supposed to fix it if they already...
if they already fixed it?
Okay.
What?
You came from that direction, right?
Yeah.
Fucking...
Did someone die?
Wait, Yellow, who died?
Who are you with?
I was by myself.
Who died?
No, you weren't.
I threw the screwdriver at you.
Oh, you're the one I stole the screwdriver from?
I was with Rin.
Blue.
What happened to Blue?
Were you separated?
I don't know.
I don't know where she went.
I went to fucking fix the screwdriver.
Thank you.
I think Rin...
I think Rin killed Mata.
Wait, Rin killed... Rin killed her?
Yeah, I saw... I saw dead Pink back there.
Yeah, but she's been dead for like 20 years.
She died first?
Yeah, she died first.
Everybody surrounded her body.
She was the first... Don't trust anyone.
Don't trust any... What about you?
Even you?
Don't trust anyone.
Really?
Even you?
Not even me.
Okay.
Let's fix the vent.
I'm here to fix my vent.
Alright.
What?
She said don't trust anybody.
I was just doing what she told me to do.
How the fuck... Did we fix...
Where is every... Did everybody die?
Hello?
Oh, no.
Oh, the red vent.
I am red.
Okay.
I don't like this.
It's so quiet.
It's so fucking quiet right now.
It's... I don't know.
Why is it... Why is it so quiet?
Guys.
Even...
What?
Oh, my God.
Welcome.
What the bad guy?
Wait.
She was the bad guy.
I don't want it.
Don't you go... Where is everyone?
After you killed someone.
She literally was like, Don't trust anybody.
Not even me.
It sounds like, okay.
And that's what you said.
And then...
You're fucking crazy.
You're like... I literally just did what she told me to do.
I had a shotgun.
I...
I don't know.
I found a shotgun at the floor.
Oh, no.
Oh, she's coming over.
She's going to shank him.
She's shank him.
You're going to stand here?
Oh, wait.
That's the last canister.
No, don't do it.
Yeah, put it in.
Right flick and then left flick.
Oh.
Wait.
There's a dead body.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, my God.
It's because you killed it innocent.
Oh, damn.
You're kidding, dude.
Stop.
What the fuck was that?
Why did you not...
I literally stared into the barrel of her gun and met my maker.
I don't f**k.
Why did you do that?
It was so funny.
I wasn't a different maker.
You were like, let me see.
Let me activate it.
Let me see if it's better than everyone f**king does.
Everybody killed each other.
Lime didn't even have to do anything.
I was like, how do I shoot this?
And she said, practice on me.
So I popped her in the head a lot.
It's okay.
I shot Juniper because Juniper was like, trust nobody.
And I was like, okay.
And then I just shot her.
I would have not shot you if I didn't.
Wait, wait, wait.
Where's Matara?
Oh yeah, right up here.
So she might have had an internet blooper.
Oh no.
Guys, the Roomba got her.
I'm gonna get you back.
No, no, no, no, no.
I've already...
True play.
You hurt me?
What?
No way.
You said your battery was low.
Yo, Matara put a f**king hex on me.
What am I gonna do?
Make a voodoo doll.
I was trying to see if it did damage, so it went through you.
And I was like, oh no, I accidentally threw it.
I didn't even register that as anything.
I just thought you were stupid.
No.
I'm trying to...
Okay, that was pretty funny.
You were like, put the battery in.
And then Lime just threw it at you.
And you were just like, okay.
Should we wait for Matara or should we do one game first?
I don't know if...
Oh, she's back.
She's Matara's internet's back.
I did not know anything.
Me either.
Oh, that's crazy.
Okay, I'll invite her.
I was watching this editorial and then got killed.
Sorry, I just wanted to taste blood.
Was it delicious?
Yes, it was so good.
Amazing.
What the f**k was that supposed to blow up though?
What the f**k was that meant to do?
We did a shot s**t for it.
We were the first ones.
If there's any of the first ones, you can tell me to turn it off immediately.
And then we'd find the like, see what colors match.
We're playing that at Life.
It's, like, fully random.
We just have to, like, narrow it down.
Hell no.
Oh, welcome back.
We back.
Thank you.
I'm sorry, Mattia.
As a consequence of not doing it right, I'm just explaining.
I readied up.
Ah, I see.
Everybody readied up, guys.
Learn your task everybody.
Hey everybody!
I'll turn down the voice volume.
Where's the voice volume?
Sorry guys, I pressed the wrong button.
I pressed the wrong button!
I was like, where's the voice volume?
And then I accidentally returned the lobby.
Okay, okay, we're good now.
We're good.
Everybody's good.
Okay, radio everyone.
Were you the cheater?
Are we okay?
Alright.
I'm ready up.
Ready up, Snuffy.
Oh god, I'm sorry.
Ready up.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, this time.
This time I didn't fuck up.
I wouldn't fuck up this time.
I promise.
Alright.
Are you a cheater?
Snuffy, are you a cheater?
No.
I gotta go clock into my nine to five.
You're nine to five.
What do I do here?
Okay, fence.
Alright, time to grab a screwdriver.
This is where the screwdriver is, right?
You guys know where the screwdrivers are?
They're gonna be this way.
Okay.
I don't trust you for once.
What?
You're the one that told me not to trust you.
Oh.
She has the gun.
Oh, is there only one?
Yeah, it's only one shot, one kill.
Okay.
Alright, heading to the fence.
Gonna do my nine to five.
Hey.
I love to...
What did you do?
Look at this.
Yeah?
Do you see it?
Look at him.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Among us.
She's a killer.
Oh, my God.
She baited me.
But don't go near my tire.
Don't listen to her.
She's gonna be like, look at this and then she's gonna slap you.
What?
Judy, Judy, come here.
Why did you do that?
I'm trying to fix the fence.
Judy, Judy, I wanna show you something suspicious.
Could you come here?
That's not Junie!
How dare you!
I can't believe it!
Do not trust her lies!
Look in front of you.
What does that look like?
I was here with you earlier!
I'm self-defense!
Self-defense!
I'm just a dumbass!
Wait!
Did you kill her?
No!
Did you?
Can you kill a dead body?
Yeah, we gotta make sure.
We gotta know if she's like resting from...
We
gotta know if she's like resting from...
No!
Oh my god!
Guys!
She was the killer!
Amelie was the killer!
Trust me!
No!
You fucker!
And then there was one.
Were you the traitor?
I should have looked for this.
There was a really um...
I can't believe it!
Don't you just like face the crowd?
Three people and three dead bodies.
I was innocent!
I died stabbing you!
Yeah, you did!
I used all your energy!
I really just had to put my whole back into it.
I knew you were gonna...
I knew you were gonna stab your...
You were gonna exhaust yourself to death.
Yeah, if you use all your energy, you fucking collapse cause you're old!
You grab...
Yeah, you had a heart attack.
I thought the death had...
Yeah...
I knew I didn't need to...
I knew I didn't need to stab you back.
I just needed you to get a heart attack.
And it worked!
But then I was left with three bodies!
I was left with three bodies!
Oh my god...
You might even win cause they need to do their task!
I don't think they know how!
Wait, can we do the task while we're dead?
Oh no!
They need to...
They need to finish the task.
I'd like to apologize.
Can you forgive me?
I apologize.
Wait, how did you kill Belle?
I stabbed her in the beginning.
I like, she even ran away.
I had no stamina.
I ran out of breath and then she literally killed me.
The end.
I like that.
What the fuck were you doing?
Running out of breath in the beginning?
I keep jumping.
I don't know, I just think it a lot.
I'm like, no, give me a chance!
And now I have no health, no stamina, and then the moment she tries to, like, kill me, I just frip and die.
Kara literally jumped once and then died.
Yeah, she did!
Oh yeah!
I wanted to make sure you were truly dead.
Yeah, you stabbed me.
You stabbed Bowden to death.
Like, to your own death.
I didn't want Bowden to wake up and kill us, you know?
Wow, thank you so much.
Now we're all dead.
So I guess we're not about dead.
Wait, how did you die?
The killer's already dead!
Why?
Why the fuck you killed me?
What do you mean the killer's already dead?
What?
Who killed you?
It's me, Tiki.
Oh!
She's on my side.
What?
I thought there was only one killer.
Wait, you think she's one of the killers or no?
I'm pretty sure there's one killer.
I think I just I think I'm just suspicious.
I think life just fucking killed you just for fun.
Because Monarch was the killer and it sounds like how did you die?
Just a little suspicious little bug.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's two killers?
Oh, there's two.
Okay, I'm gonna say it's a one.
Two is way too many.
Let's go see what's happening.
We're just gonna kill each other.
Who is the other one?
I don't know.
It has to be Lyme then, right?
Loaded in.
Where is everybody?
Oh, there they are!
Whoa!
What did you do?
How did you die?
This is what I get for trying to negotiate.
You never negotiate.
Never negotiate with traitors.
What did you do?
Well, she found the gun and then I said could you try not having found the gun?
Oh, oh, oh.
How is she the killer again?
Oh my god.
It was Monarch in her.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I didn't play what we ever...
Every time we just went through how much fun we were having.
Oh my god, that was so cute!
I'm doing...
I'm making it beginner mode.
You...
You know what you did.
You know what you did for stick.
Oh my god.
The music did not begin.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, where is it?
Wait, is the music DMCA?
I'm really sorry if it is.
I did not know.
I don't think it really matters.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna make it so that the task is like super easy.
I'm gonna make everything one.
Every single time I look at your POV, you're just doing tasks.
You're looking at your tablet.
You're doing your best.
Okay.
We need you, bro.
Alright.
Okay, I have...
I have literally two tasks.
Alright.
Is this easier now?
Oh my god.
There's literally two tasks.
There's no way.
There's literally two tasks, everybody.
We can win.
Employees, let's go.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna go make pizza.
How do I make pizza?
Oh wait.
How do I get to pizza?
There's no way we can fuck up.
Where's the pizza room?
Oh my god, it's this way.
What does this mean?
Are you making pizza?
I don't know.
It's pizza sushi.
You put it in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta look at the computer.
We can't fuck it up.
It's literally two tasks.
If we fail this, we don't deserve to be paid.
There's no...
We can just eat the pizza ourselves and blame it on someone else.
Okay.
I think we go to the diner first.
Oh, the diner?
Okay.
It's a great icon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll follow you because you're watching the tutorial.
Surely.
You watched it, right?
Oh yeah, uh-huh.
Okay, maybe, like, the customer?
Are you figuring it out?
Am I doing it?
I think so.
What is this?
It's a container.
Okay.
Do we have rice?
Where do we get rice?
Okay, let's see.
Alright, we go here.
Press the button?
Nope.
You need the container.
Oh, you put the container.
Wait.
You have the container?
Maybe we go grab rice from the garden?
Isn't nature beautiful?
And then we get it.
You have the container, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Isn't this rice?
The blue flower?
Is this rice?
It's blue.
Blue equals rice?
I put it in here.
I put it in.
Oh, I knew it!
Blue equals rice!
I don't know.
I think I just heard gunshots.
Did you hear that?
No.
Was that not just gunshots?
If we can't complete...
Maybe...
Maybe we need one task.
Hello?
Are you safe?
Are you guys safe?
We're just trying to get rice!
We're just trying!
There's only one traitor.
Were you guys together?
Yeah.
We were trying to figure this out.
I think it was Mata then.
She spotted us across the room.
Okay.
Then...
Whoa!
You can't just walk up to somebody unarmed!
I got somebody vouching for me.
You dropped this.
Here you go.
Oh, wait.
Who vouches?
It's my rice.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's our rice.
We're trying to figure out...
The dissidents are shooting each other.
Okay.
There's only one traitor.
I only put one traitor this time.
The person who shot at us...
This is all I heard.
Cackling after shooting both of us.
I thought it was Rin, but I'm not sure.
It looked dark blue.
And then all I heard was...
Well, it has to be Rin.
I'm not sure.
The end result is that we're colorblind.
I genuinely thought it was Doki.
It's not me!
I was making rice!
Did we figure it out?
Is that it?
Oh my god.
You're a genius.
I don't think that was rice.
I still don't know how to do a repeat thing.
Am I supposed to make rice?
That's what we're trying to figure out too!
We're trying to make pizza!
Oh wait!
We have to go back to green!
We're so stupid!
I just looked at the video!
I thought you were looking at the video!
Go to green!
Why were you looking at the video?
Look!
This is the instructions!
I think I killed the killer.
Who was the killer?
I think Rin was the killer.
We got to do this in three minutes!
We have to work together in three minutes!
Is this right?
Rin shot me and then she said that.
Where's the rice?
Okay, so we need these two.
We have BO4.
And then...
Process.
Oh!
We're doing it!
Oh my god!
No guys!
We all have to work together!
Guys!
And then...
What do we do?
Oh!
And then we check it!
I'm hurting!
Do we do it?
We have to do this!
Oh!
Here!
And then...
And then that is this!
Oh!
Can we do it?
What happened to it?
What happened?
Where did it go?
Do we do it?
I don't have the analysis.
Can we fuck it up?
Bro, it's cooked.
I don't want to kill anybody!
Look at the ingredient wall.
The ingredient wall.
Okay.
Guys!
Please!
We have two minutes!
We have to finish two tasks, guys!
We gotta work together!
There's a dispenser!
We gotta...
There's a dispenser?
Let me grab the stuff first!
We're so...
Guys!
We're running out of time!
How did we fuck this up?
Two tasks is too many!
Oh my god!
How did we not get two tasks correctly?
I don't understand!
Oh my god.
How do...
How do I get this...
I don't know how did she put stores in her container.
It's so weird.
Oh my god.
Oh it's dirty!
We just need an empty container.
We need to clean this.
We need to clean this container.
We have to clean it.
I don't think we are going to do this in 30 seconds.
We have 30 seconds.
The tool room.
Okay.
We can clean it in here.
Alright.
Guys we are going to win.
We are going to do it.
I'm going to put one task.
No, we can't figure it out.
You can't figure it out.
You can do all of the aspects for us.
We never actually pull it.
You're literally white right sitting here.
You can't pull it.
My hands are wet.
My hands hurt.
You country agree.
You stole like 20 years.
I don't believe you bought.
Wait, did you all throw this way?
Were you the traitor?
How did you get caught?
I'm not fair anyone!
Just shoot somebody!
Okay, there's only one task!
What the fuck we got?
There's only one task everybody!
The real day in the op.
Guys!
How can we?
How?
There's only one task!
There's no way!
There's only one!
Okay.
There's no way!
Okay!
This is the one that I thought we had to do in the analogy.
Oh, it is!
So now we do the thing that we weren't doing.
Yeah!
We can do this!
Why is everybody walking the di- Wait, we're walking the wrong direction.
No, that's us!
That's us!
Oh my god!
Alright guys, these are the ingredients on the wall!
These are the ingredients!
I need a blue cup one!
Okay, do I have- do I have a container?
Where are the containers?
This video is far too long and my attention span wasn't built, but I didn't need you to shut the room behind me a lot.
Bro, Pal and I have been trying to figure this out for like eight minutes.
We were doing the wrong task!
We were doing the wrong one!
How the fuck did we do this to ourselves?
This is so stupid.
Oh my god.
Okay guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Do you remember what the heck it needed?
Like, I don't know.
I'm just gonna grab something.
I'm pretty sure there's a mushroom.
I got a mushroom.
Alright.
I have a mushroom.
Do we need a mushroom?
I knew it.
Okay.
I have a mushroom.
We can do this!
We can do one task!
And then we put it here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We put it in analysis.
Yes, we're doing it guys!
We're doing it!
We're actually...
Kool-aid.
And then put it here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna watch this.
Ready to analysis?
Oh my god.
Did we do it?
We did it!
We won!
We finished one task!
We did it!
We did it.
I literally found the code and went, alright, it's time.
And then the game ended.
We had to learn how to do one...
alright.
Okay.
Guys, okay, I'm gonna up the difficulty now, after we've leveled up from one task.
We can do now more than one!
We're gonna do three tasks!
We're gonna do three tasks, everybody!
I hope three is enough!
No, three is not enough!
Okay, alright, alright, everybody!
I believe in you guys!
Alright, I'm gonna do a scanner!
Alright, how do you use a scanner?
We go to a scanner...
Yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna walk while going there.
I'm gonna do a scanner.
Okay.
Yeah!
I'm gonna go in!
Alright.
Yeah.
Yeah!
We have to position you?
Oh!
Okay.
I got it.
Everybody knows I'm very good at directions.
...
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Oh, and then look a little low.
Alright.
Go back up a little.
A little upper.
Up.
Oh, look left.
Look left.
You just have to look.
Left a little.
A little lower.
Oh, I hear it.
Oh, oh.
Yeah.
Did I do it?
Yeah, you did it.
Okay, next one.
Do it three more times.
Lower.
If there's two of us, can you do it with multiple people?
Can you imagine how confusing that would get?
Stay there.
We did it!
Hard right.
Yeah, okay.
Right there.
Go lower.
Oh, look at me go.
Lower.
Oh, perfect.
Wow.
What's up?
What you up to?
Killing people?
You up to killing people?
No.
And a little bit right.
Yeah, you did it!
Yeah!
Am I done?
Yeah, you're done.
Yeah, we did it!
We just need analysis!
Oh my god, we're figuring it out!
We're doing it!
You did it!
Oh my god, easiest game of my life.
It was so good.
Oh my god, the traitor can't do nothing now.
What is she gonna do?
Kill us?
Oh, we need a container.
Can I have you guys come with me?
I want to show you something really important.
Sure.
That sounds like something a traitor will do.
But I like danger.
Yeah.
Have you ever looked up at the sky and wondered is the moon real?
It's not all the time.
That's not the moon.
That's Saturn.
What?
Oh, you're right.
Saturn?
Did someone just try and throw a knife at us and we feel at it?
Look.
We did that.
What's with the knife here?
What's happening?
Oh my god.
This is clearly Neptune.
What?
What happened?
Wait.
I thought...
It's all good.
Dude, I'm such a sucker.
It's a shootout.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm not the killer.
And then...
Let me pick it up and then press E so it's safe in your pocket.
Hi.
But which one of you is the imposter from Among Us?
Also the imposter from Among Us.
Wait.
Is somebody still alive?
Who's still alive?
Oh my god.
Life is still alive.
Life's just trying to do her task.
She's just...
How dare she do this to my face.
Oh my god.
Life's still alive and she's just trying to do tasks.
Killstreak.
Who gave Batara a knife?
Oh, I did.
I gave her the knife.
Guys, I think it was my fault.
I threw a knife at Batara and set everything up.
I gave her...
I accidentally gave her the knife, guys.
I...
You died?
How did you die?
I thought I was the last one left and I didn't know how to do tasks so I just died.
Life is still alive.
I know.
I wanted you guys to look at the moon.
I'm feeling philosophical.
Oh my god.
All that did was put us in the same place with our backs to the door.
You're crazy.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna clutch this.
Has she even done any of the tasks?
She still needs to do three.
We have one task.
Oh my god.
That's the task.
Where is she?
Does Lime even know how to do it?
Where did she go?
Where did Lime go?
We're missing someone.
She's still alive.
Lime, she's literally the last one.
She's over there.
She's not even doing tasks.
I think she's trying to hide from you, Matara.
She doesn't know you're dead.
Yeah, three analysis.
Okay.
Maybe I should have given us two tasks.
Maybe three was a little too much.
Maybe four was too much.
What the fuck?
She doesn't know.
I have to analyze the task for 27 seconds.
That doesn't seem likely, huh?
Lime, no!
No!
Because everyone is dead.
How was Rinda's question that she never knew we asked?
Okay, so I needed...
Oh god.
I don't remember what the plants looked like.
You can look at the window, Lime!
Look at the window!
Okay, okay.
Sure.
Lime!
Alright, thank you, DC.
What?
She's still in it.
No!
How did we lose?
We had four tasks!
What the fuck?
Did you die?
You were gone and we couldn't see your ghost.
Did you try to kill me?
Did you do anything?
Yeah.
But Tara thought she was the last one alive.
And then she killed herself.
Did you shoot me in the back?
Oh my god.
I wasn't expecting to see you any minute.
We'll never...
We'll never be able to...
We'll never be able to win.
No, no, no, no, no.
We'll never be able to win, guys.
We're gonna get to our backs or something.
You're the best!
Alright.
I'll start...
I'll start us off.
I want to!
Please!
I just want us to win a game.
Guys.
Please.
Yes we are!
Yes we can!
We can do it!
Also sad guy never asked you, but hope the volume is okay now.
That's why I went in the corner to ask you.
All right, pressure.
I shall watch the video.
Oh, that one's too hard.
I'm gonna do a delivery.
All right.
Okay.
We go over here.
We go to the storage area.
Okay.
No, I'm not.
I'm fucking leaving.
I'm never trusting you again.
Okay.
Oh, hey, there's three boxes and there's three of us.
Math-wise, this should work.
Wait, where are the boxes?
Oh, there's the boxes.
Yeah, I found one.
Okay, medical.
Okay.
I found the medical boxes.
What does it say after that?
And then I put it... Oh, I just put it in here.
Okay.
Where's the... Where's the little box thing?
Can't be that hard now, right?
But it's just nearly one task.
You did a task?
No.
No, please, let me do the task.
Please.
Wait...
Wait.
I'm sorry!
I was actually the killer.
I was actually the killer at the start.
I didn't even know I had it at once.
No!
Brynn!
Finish my job, Brynn!
Finish my job!
No!
Brynn!
What are they called?
Like, crimes of passion?
No!
I love you so much!
My dad!
I just wanted to finish my job!
What was that millennial meme?
Still a better love story than Twilight?
Oh, God!
Oh, my God!
Did I finish my job?
Did I have my one, only job?
Ducky, if I don't get to finish, nobody gets to finish.
That's how it works.
Wow!
I'm a one and done!
They delivered something!
Oh, my God.
How did Mata die?
She fucking stabbed me so hard.
She got a heart attack.
That's how she died.
Oh, my God.
Did I do it?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
How did you die?
Okay.
That one was red.
Did I do it?
What happened to me?
Did I die?
You didn't learn from my death at all.
I died in vain.
Sorry.
Did they quit?
Did they even finish it?
They just quit.
I was dying all green.
It was fine for the first time.
And it had swollen the first time.
Did not check up?
Why did...
Oh, no!
It was green!
Someone switched them!
Someone?!
Oh, yes!
Wait,
was it Bao that rearranged it?
I don't know if it's a safe mission.
Oh!
Come here, baby!
Oh, it's not where... Oh, no!
Oh, okay, they're fine.
It's just...
Okay, they're just missing one.
No, no, it's because she didn't stand next to it!
You don't stand there!
Oh, okay, so... Okay, so that's not right.
Is she...
It's literally everybody else dead.
I think... Wait, is it?
One, two, three, four, five.
There's still two people missing.
Um, I'll take this.
Okay?
And then...
Can I try this again?
Since I know that one was...
Howard.
Okay.
Is she gonna do it?
I'm gonna figure out this mask.
Did I do it?
Did she do it?
Who told her that?
I don't know.
It's not exploding!
I think she did it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I did it, I think?
She did it!
Can you ban them for that?
Wait, but I did it.
You did it!
What?
Oh, then she just has to put that into...
But, but...
She did it!
You did it!
Don't do anything!
What are you doing?
I'm confused now.
Am I getting confused, or is she confused with me?
I'm starting to get confused now!
I don't understand this task at all!
Did you watch the video?
Did you watch...
What do I do?
You just need a new red.
I did!
I wish I could pick up my tablet and watch while it did.
Yes!
Grab the tablet!
Get another red.
I believe in you, Bao.
Pull my tablet up.
Where's another red?
Guys, this is why we're all VTubers.
We're not meant to do a 9 to 5.
This is why we're VTubers.
Guys, we can't understand.
We can't understand a simple task.
Where's the red?
Who wants to learn?
I want to learn.
God, I love your eyebrows.
Oh, thank you.
You look mischievous.
Oh, I do?
It's so cute.
What?
You look like a mischievous potato.
Yeah, that's me.
We literally have, like, caterpillar eyebrows.
You need to claim that title.
Oh my god.
Did we find... what is she doing?
Wait, I'm kidding.
What?
You had it!
Why are you so quick?
This is my chat trolling.
Yeah, it's the same.
She's getting us.
There's only eight of us.
Hang on, guys.
She's got it.
What's this?
I'm watching her brain expand right now.
Live.
Not listening.
My fat is being bad.
Oh, no.
Now we don't have time.
Guys, it's 20 seconds.
Don't worry.
Bao's got this.
No, no, no.
She's so exhausted.
You guys look so, like, fed up.
Yeah, that's what I did.
Okay, I'll increase the time for the next one.
This is the task!
There's no... we're gonna figure this out!
I'll increase the time!
I'll make it like 15... oh my god!
That's the only time!
Okay, I got an idea!
Okay, guys!
Okay, guys, I have an idea!
I'm gonna give us... I'm gonna give us 17 minutes on just the pressure!
I'm gonna put 17 minutes on just pressure!
We're all gonna figure this out!
We're all gonna figure it out together!
Alright, everybody!
It's just all of us on pressure!
All of us figuring it out together!
We're all gonna figure it out together!
Here we go!
As long as we're all here, we'll learn!
Yeah, I want to try!
We can do this!
We need to find all the canisters, first.
Okay, we gotta get all the canisters.
Alright!
I  you in all the rub!
I swear she killed herself!
I swear to god she killed herself!
I swear to god she was like this I swear on him!
I did zero jump to death!
I believe you!
I swear to god, I swear on him!
I want to see what the f*** happened!
There is nothing in this bar that is more believable...
I know!
I just wonder what the f*** is up to?
Mmmmm mmm mmm That's what they all say.
That's what they all say.
Guys, I just want us to figure out pressure.
Okay.
How do we do this?
I almost jumped to death again.
Wait.
Let's just put it.
What's the worst that could happen?
Okay.
Just that.
It's just that one.
Okay.
So the worst did happen.
So the worst did...
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Okay.
It's just these guys.
Alright.
So the worst...
I got you.
The worst did happen by the way.
Oh my god.
We'll figure this out.
We're gonna figure this out together.
We did it.
Nice.
Okay.
Then we put it here.
Okay We got it!
But this one worked!
I got the other one!
That's not it.
It's okay.
They can do this.
I don't think that's the alarm.
We can figure this out.
Because I got this one correct!
I got this one correct!
There's no way!
We have 13 minutes!
There's only one!
Just do it!
That's what I thought last time!
That one worked!
That wasn't supposed to.
This one wouldn't work!
I thought we figured it out!
I got her!
I thought we were...
Were you trading again?
I just saw a gun on the ground!
I'm just like, I got her!
I'm like, I'm on vacation.
So I'm just feeling kind of chaotic.
How did you die?
Because I heard gunshots.
Yeah, live shot her!
Yeah!
He's got all his gunshots and the damn pressure thing going on.
Who is the actual killer?
I don't know.
There's so many people that died.
It could be.
I think the killer just wants us to finish this job.
The killer just wants us to finish this one job.
Is there another...
Is there another canister that we're missing?
There can't be another canister, right?
Is that it, chat?
Like, what is going...
How did we not figure this out?
There isn't, so we just...
It's just the order.
How do we...
Just do the order!
Just swap the red and the yellow!
No, we're watching them.
Wait, why did she remove the other canister?
We figured it out!
Do you say that's bullshit?
Or do you say...
Why don't you take it away?
No, look at me.
Look at me.
Look at me!
I think more cigarettes are cool and I think more children should be smoking them.
Woah.
You know what, Matara?
I disagree with you.
Because I think children should be vaping instead.
Guys, for legal reasons, it's a joke.
For legal reasons.
For legal reasons, we're joking.
Please, please, I'm just fucking around because I'm dead.
You know how there's a candy cigarette?
We should have candy vapes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah, those are great too.
Yeah, I had one as well.
How did she mess up this one?
How did she figure this out?
Your deaths went to vain.
Your deaths never mattered.
Oh my god.
Wait, they do have candy vapes?
What the fuck?
Oh yeah.
Wait, how do you know about candy vapes?
They gotta get the yellow one.
Wait, which flavour?
No, the yellow one's the bubble gum.
I know where the yellow one is.
It was me.
It was you?
I came to stand in front of it.
I killed you!
I did it!
I killed the killer!
I did my job!
I'm gonna win this game!
I'm gonna win my second game!
They're doing this.
I can't...
It's just one task.
It's really...
I should've given them 20 minutes.
I should go and look at the moon.
I should just go and stare at this guy.
I'm fucking
scared.
I don't understand.
I don't understand how...
This game is too much for us.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the game.
It's not us, guys.
Guys, it's not us.
It's not us.
This game is just very difficult.
This game...
This video game is crazy.
I'm afraid it's not meant to comprehend this.
We're VTubers.
Yeah, blame the game, not the player.
Yeah.
Blame the game, not the player.
It's not my fault I can't read.
It's the game's fault for not reading the instructions out to us.
The game should have better accessibility by reading the instructions instead of having us reading it.
Yeah, but the video had zero narration and that was the problem.
The game needed narration.
Why were the tasks video form but the tutorial didn't give us these tasks and the tutorial?
How?
We had 19 minutes!
How are we still doing this?
How many VTubers does it take to do the... Please!
Please!
Oh!
Wait!
They did it!
Are they doing it?
Please!
Oh!
Wait!
Did it work?
No way!
What is the task?
Wait!
Yeah!
I did it!
Oh my gosh!
You just did it!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
If you start from the lowest canisters and then hop power them.
If they pop, they need a higher canister.
So you go from the lowest you can possibly do.
And then if they pop you, you upgrade the canister.
Oh my gosh!
Alright, Lime.
You're on canister duty.
Lime, you're on...
You did it!
So surely this time we're ready to do two entire tasks.
Yeah!
Are we guys... Are we ready?
Are we actually ready, guys?
I think we should do three.
Alright.
I'm putting it on.
Alright, guys.
I believe in... Three tasks?
Alright, three tasks.
I think we should do it.
Alright.
I'm going to put three tasks on.
I'm going to do it.
Oh my gosh.
We finally did it.
We figured out pressure.
We fucking figured...
Alright, guys.
Three different tasks.
Pressure, scanner, and delivery.
It's pressure.
I want to do pressure.
Pressure, pressure.
I'm doing delivery!
Delivery is the easiest.
So I call dibs.
Okay, where's pressure?
Yeah!
You just deliver things.
Okay, okay.
Delivery.
Okay.
Wait, what is this?
Okay, security.
I got one of the boxes.
We can do this, guys.
Pressure!
By the time we could... By the time we figure this out, we can quit our jobs as VTubers and go back to minimum wage.
By the time we could...
By the time we figure this out, we can quit our jobs as VTubers and go back to minimum wage.
Okay, this way.
It's not gonna be a loss.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
To make sure nobody starts killing.
I did it.
Did I do it?
How many deliveries do I have to do?
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Wait, what do I do after I put it in?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
We just... Okay, I gotta go back to the boxes.
Do delivery with me.
We gotta do our jobs.
Alright, this way.
Oh, you're already getting another delivery going.
Okay.
Alright, where are some more boxes?
Oh, I got another box!
PC.
I'm going to the PC room.
There's another box over there!
Wait, what?
Why did I hear that?
I didn't say anybody got a knife.
Okay.
Wait, that was a gunshot.
I think Snuffy killed somebody or...
I think... I think Snuffy already killed somebody.
That was a gunshot right there.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
The gunshot was this way.
Oh, there they are!
There you guys are!
Alright, I'll watch.
I'll watch.
I'll film it.
I'll film it like a documentary.
Alright, do you guys just say any, like...
Any final words?
Wait, you guys should give, like, confessions.
You should guys give confessions to each other.
I know we just met, but knowing that our birthdays are, like, ten days apart from Valentine's Day is so romantic.
I think so, too.
I think that the biggest sign for me to know that we were always destined to be together was that the day that you landed on Earth was that special fourth day.
The day that brings us together.
Oh, my God.
My God, it's empty.
Your God is empty?
Were you trying to shoot her before?
Were you trying to kill her before she could finish her line?
I'm gonna take his whole life.
Oh, my...
What the fuck?
Okay, so I heard three gunshots while we were listening.
Hey, how come I heard three gunshots while the...
while it was happening?
That was definitely just part of the background noise, I think.
Yeah, probably the background noise?
Okay.
If you say so.
All right.
Why did I hear another gunshot?
Don't worry about it.
That's just the background environment.
Why did I hear that?
Oh, it's the pressure.
It was the pressure.
Wait, where is that going to?
It's always...
I'm still trying to do pressure.
Wait, did somebody die?
Somebody... did somebody die?
Wait.
There's still three deliveries.
Woo!
The box!
Oh, boom!
Boom, skip!
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom!
Boom!
Val tried to smack me with a box!
She's a killer!
Okay.
Okay, wait, let me do this.
Let me do this first.
I'm going to be the guard at the door.
Wait, wait.
Give me that box.
I need that box.
We need complete delivery.
It's F, F, press F.
I have bad news.
I have forgotten how to drop things.
Press F.
Right-click, left-click.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Computer.
Oh, nice.
Okay, guys.
I need...
Val has the final delivery.
Guys, guys.
Val's holding the final delivery box hostage.
We have to kill her together.
She's literally holding the last box.
We can't kill her.
We have to complete it.
We have to kill...
We got to kill her.
Guys, okay.
I'm going to smack her, guys.
You guys defend me.
We got it.
We got to kill her.
You guys got to get this.
Guys, we have two minutes.
Get over here, Val.
Okay, let's finish this job.
Let's finish this.
Okay.
Okay, we did it.
Oh, no.
This is the computer room.
All right.
Where the fuck is the thing?
Okay.
We killed her.
We did it, guys.
Yippie.
Where the fuck is the thing for this?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's over here.
Are you going to do the scanner with me?
Yeah.
Let me put this last box.
Wait.
What?
You have to deliver the last box.
We're going to do the scanner.
Yeah.
I know.
Alright, you guys, why don't you guys do the scatter?
This goes to... we have two minutes.
Alright, I'll do scatter, I'll do scatter.
I'll do scatter since I'm already good at this.
Okay, Rin, you deliver.
Rin, you deliver.
And then I do scan.
I'll do the direction.
Alright, wait, it's here, it's here.
Okay, okay, I'm standing in the middle.
Hurry!
One minute, 30 seconds.
This is it.
This is the last one.
Okay, to your right, a little bit, a little nudge.
Yeah.
The delivery isn't done either, for what it's worth.
Yeah, right there, hold.
Yeah.
Okay, go left, a little bit.
Little bit more.
Up two little bits.
Again.
Up.
Right a little bit.
Okay, hold.
Okay.
Go really far left.
Uh, yep.
Oh, a little bit more right.
Yeah, right there, and then down a little bit.
Little bit more.
Right there, hold.
How many more left?
Right a little bit.
Go right a little bit.
Uh, go down.
Down.
Right there, hold.
Uh, go really far right.
Uh, go up.
We can do this!
Really far up.
Okay.
Okay, perfect.
Uh, hold.
Right like a hair.
Yeah, hold.
Go left.
A little bit left.
Go down.
No pressure, but you have 13 seconds.
No pressure, but if you fail this, you have 10 seconds.
Go up a little bit.
Okay, go, go really far right.
13 seconds.
No!
Why did you stop?
Why did you?
Why?
Why did you stop?
We could have done it.
We did it!
Yeah!
Yeah, we were so close!
I literally have brain damage.
We could have done it.
Thank you.
How many did I have left?
You had two more.
No!
I can't believe you took the box hostage!
I can't believe it!
We caught you!
Oh my gosh!
Guys, please, employees have to win a regular game!
I swear!
We just need one regular win as an employee!
Guys, please!
We can do this!
Oh my gosh!
Alright, scatter!
Who wants to do scatter?
I'm going to do the scatter!
Somebody do it!
I'm going to do the scatter first!
I learned my lesson!
Alright.
Alright, I'm so well versed in the scatter.
I can do it!
Alright, now that there's zero pressure!
Now that there's zero pressure!
Do you want to scatter?
Alright.
Okay.
More up.
Alright.
Up quite a bit.
Quite a bit.
Yep, yep, yep.
Down just slightly.
There you go.
Oh my god, alright, seven left.
Hop a square.
A bit more.
Cool, down.
And then right slightly.
Right, kind of like diagonal.
And then, yep, down.
Perfect, there we go.
You can go down for three seconds.
Yes!
You sabotaged, Snuffy.
A little bit.
Wait, you just, oh my god, you can overlap.
Holy shit, you just went to the other side.
Okay, go up.
Up, up, up, up.
Keep going until I say.
Keep going, keep going, stop.
And right.
Stop and down.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
A bit more, a bit more diagonal downish.
Right.
Oh, I see it!
I got it!
Yep, left.
Up there.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Stop.
And up.
And right.
Snuffy, I swear to god, I see you have a screwdriver.
I swear to god, Snuffy.
I swear to god, I worked so hard for this.
I swear to god.
If you're gonna kill us, kill us after we do the scan.
Please.
Go right.
Kill us after we do the scan.
I swear to god.
Further down and right.
There you go, perfect.
Down, down, down.
Keep going.
Full square down.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Faster, faster, faster, faster.
You got this, you got this.
Okay, and...
And left slightly and down.
Okay.
There you go, perfect.
And left.
Snuffy, I swear to god.
I swear to god.
And left.
She's like the kid with the...
I got it.
I'm so alive.
I'm so pleased.
I didn't even finish.
You couldn't let me finish this.
What's gonna happen?
You said something.
Snuffy, I thought you were gonna protect us.
Snuffy, why were you...
You didn't protect us.
I killed this guy.
You're supposed to kill Matara.
I just started blasting.
I went to go kill Bao.
And I stabbed her once.
Oh my god.
She died before I could kill her.
I was so close.
I was so close to finishing that task.
I just wanted to finish Tanner.
We all were like two left.
I requested to die after.
How many times is Matara the traitor?
Guys, we need to kill Matara first.
She's always the traitor.
Guys.
Employee meeting right now.
I vote that we kill Matara first.
Oh my gosh, she is.
She's gonna fucking eat her head.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
We need to kill her first next game.
We need to kill her first.
Why is somebody talking?
We're haunting.
We're haunting you.
Guys.
Wait, who's still alive?
Who's still alive?
Who's hiding?
Who the fuck is still alive?
Oh my god.
The voices.
What do the voices say?
Oh my god.
There's so many dead bodies.
What do the voices say?
Wait.
She's gonna do this herself.
Holy shit, she's gaming.
Oh my god.
I was gaming.
She's actually gaming right now.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
She's just leaving her so vulnerable to Mataya when she comes in.
Oh no.
She's alone though.
She's leaving herself vulnerable to Mataya.
Zara!
She's just standing there!
Defenseless!
She's doing better than both me and you did together.
She go!
What?!
What do you mean?!
I don't think...
Oh!
Up!
Come on!
She's so close!
Stop!
Stop going down!
Yes!
She did it!
What a game!
She's such a game!
She has 30 seconds!
Go live!
No!
Save me!
What happened?!
Save her!
Oh god!
Come on!
Don't do it!
She has 10 seconds!
Don't even look at the tablet!
We did it!
Only one second!
Oh my god!
I'm so...
We did it!
What the hell?
Really?!
We're okay!
I just like...
Real quick!
I just like to go over our battle strategy for the next game.
So...
You die!
Go on!
We kill Matara first!
She dies!
Statistically we have to kill her!
We all agree!
End of board meeting!
In our board meeting, we have decided that Matara dies first!
Alright!
We're starting the game!
Yeah!
If she refuses, we follow her to do tasks!
We bad!
You should pick up your weapon!
I won't give you the weapon, Matara.
We will judge your performance.
We will...
I know what you are...
We know what you are...
And you just aren't the father!
...in uniform!
We're gonna stab her like Julius Caesar.
Hell yeah, hell yeah!
Why would I be training?
I'm always in play!
It doesn't matter.
Do your task.
That's what they all say.
Alright, but Tara should do the scanner.
I hereby dub this the scanner girl.
Let's go.
Alright, we're gonna put her in the square.
We're gonna put her in the square.
Let's go.
We're in the square.
Scam me.
I'll go.
Alright.
Wait, the scanner's this way.
Okay, I forgot where it was.
This way.
It's to the right.
Alright.
Okay, get in that...
Tara, please.
Please.
It's literally one square.
No!
Look, look, look.
It's empty.
I swear to God, Dokie.
I swear to God it's in here.
It's not empty, Dokie.
I promise you.
It's not...
It's not empty!
You shot me in the gut!
You had two bullets in the gut!
Oh my God.
Apparently, it's empty with my other hand.
I thought it was the gun that was empty.
Rather than literally everybody, the traffic could not be prevented.
I just wanted to do this again.
I just wanted to...
Okay, let's say right.
Let's say right.
Okay, right.
You shot me in the gut.
I like how you didn't register that you shot me in the gut.
And you're just like, how did she die?
How did you do that?
I don't know how many times I have to repeat this again.
You shot me in the gut.
Because you shot me in the head, so I jumped on the fleek flex.
And that was my last HP.
That was really my last HP.
Oh, my God.
It'll take some time, but it might get the best of you.
I got it, everybody else.
Yeah.
That was bad.
I know.
It's okay.
My sacrifice to eliminate you was worth it.
Everyone shall live now, technically.
Everyone shall live.
I wasn't the enemy.
Proceeds to shoot me.
Red flags have red flags.
Oh my god, they're cooking!
Can I be your scary dog outside while you do this?
They're cooking!
Do you have any guns?
Not for defense.
There's only one traitor.
If it's not Matara, it's somebody in this group.
VTuber does not know what vegetables are.
I just watched her shoot somebody.
She's coming over here.
Wait, who killed you?
Amelie, who killed you?
Wait, Amelie died.
Where did she go?
There's no pressure.
So what exploded?
There's no pressure!
I'm running from the crime!
Oh shit!
What?
Lime is definitely the killer.
So I have to...
Blaster!
Killer!
Uh-oh.
It's not me!
You're a catch-up to her!
I'm gonna run to death!
Help!
Bad boy, bad boy.
What is she doing?
Oh my god.
Shoot her!
What?
What is she doing?
She's throwing a gun!
That's a cassette tape!
No!
She's gonna get away!
How did she keep getting guns?
She found three guns!
Oh shit!
How did you not find a gun and Lime found three?
She found three guns!
Those were all her empty guns.
Oh my god, she's scheming.
Wait, did she kill you?
I don't know.
I don't know what the detonator did.
I don't think it does nothing.
I think that means...
Why are you detonating?
What are you...
Oh my god.
Juniper, our final hope.
You stay away!
Juniper, just kill it!
Juniper!
I know what you are!
Get up!
Juniper, why did you just watch it?
Juniper!
Why?
Why did you just watch?
Fucking, I know what you are!
By the way, you needed C4 with the detonator, Snuffy.
You need it.
There's not even C4 anywhere.
Where is it?
I don't fucking know.
Apparently, there's a C4 with the detonator.
It was like 200...
There's 200 bombs, 200 guns, but one detonator.
I guess so.
You can play C4 and then...
Oh my god, I wanna do that.
But like...
Wait, what did the detonator look like?
Wait, Snuffy, show me what the detonator looked like.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, is that it?
Yeah.
Oh, apparently it looks like a battery pack.
We should look for the C4!
We should look at what the C4...
It looks like a battery pack.
Let's find a C4 so we can do it next game.
Yeah, I wonder too.
Is that the C4?
Oh, yeah, that's the battery.
Yeah, that is!
That is!
That's the C4!
Okay, we should trick...
Okay, apparently somebody can hold onto the C4 and detonate it.
Like, detonate it.
We should trick someone into holding it next game.
No, no, no, no, no way.
Because it definitely says C4 when you pick it up.
Yeah, but nobody reads.
We're all YouTubers.
We have to have it be like...
Somebody is like...
Bow.
They take the fall.
You know, they kick...
No, no, no.
You know what this is.
Just go up to people and be like, hey everybody, what are we doing?
Just let it...
Just let it grind, you know?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna... My next game, I'm just gonna try and find C4.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all go here and we'll be like...
I'm the leader.
I can set up the lobby so that we have a task that we haven't done before.
Dr. Carol!
What?
Oh, dear.
Okay, wait, wait.
You're making pizza?
Tell the Latinas I love them, sorry.
Is she the last one?
At least she's letting her finish pizza.
She really is.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how did you die, Juniper?
Juniper, you had a gun.
How did you die?
It had no ammo.
It was empty.
Did you just let her stab you?
It was kind of pathetic.
Wait, what happened?
What happened, Matara?
It had no ammo.
I stabbed her in the back.
I guess I put a melee with like a container or something.
I guess I forgot I could do that.
You could have grabbed the battery pack or something.
And slapped her.
Oh my god, Lab's just playing with her food right now.
She bounced the last one.
Container.
Container though.
That was so painful.
Well, at least we can learn how to make sushi.
Oh my god, that's lame.
She's like, oh, this could be a lot easier for all of us.
Surely.
We forced the whales to make sushi before that.
That's fucked.
Before that.
Now the ferret eats her.
She's marinating her.
Yeah, she's literally marinating.
Oh no.
The ferret's gonna get a juicy pizza with some whale toppings.
That would be delicious.
Oh.
She's sizing her up.
Oh god.
It's gonna be delicious.
Did we successfully make peace sushi?
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Then the rice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Then I need to get some shrimp.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Oh no.
Suits activation.
Tuna, salmon.
What?
Tuna?
Salmon?
No.
Where do I get the shrimp?
Oh.
Where did she get the fish?
The shrimp button.
And what happens?
If you prison more than once, does it...
Oh, oh.
Oh.
There you go.
I like how it's the traitor teaching the...
The employee how to do the task.
Lime has to be the only one that knows how to read out of all of us.
She's the only one that knows how to read.
This might be the win.
All Lime has is a knife.
She can...
She can run if she completes the task.
She just feels...
What about the alimentations?
Which I'm not sure about.
Where'd they go?
I kinda want to...
Oh, that's the one where you need to find the plant and stuff.
I think, right?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Did we get the sushi?
At least we know how to make food.
Wait, where did they go?
I know.
I'm like, wow.
I'm learning so many things.
We're learning so...
It only took two hours.
Oh, no!
Yes!
But I finished the sign.
And I could not turn on the camera.
Oh, you killed the camera.
Get off camera.
That is so fucked.
You'reicasy.
That was killing her.
That's so fucked.
Yeah.
You are activated.
You're married to her.
You're so fucked.
God, you live in a window where there's nothing to see.
You are a freaky freaky girl.
You literally marinated Bao.
We never got her pizza sushi.
She would have made the pizza sushi.
Oh God.
You gave up on her.
You didn't believe in her enough to finish the task.
You didn't believe in her.
No, God is my favorite ingredient in pizza sushi.
It's kind of hard when there's a screwdriver pointing at you.
The more pressure, the faster you go.
Guys, we can get...
Guys, we need to be able to get one win as an employee, guys.
In a normal game.
We can do it.
I believe.
Guys, we can get one win.
It's not me.
It's totally not me.
Yeah, it's totally not us too.
Yeah.
What have we got?
Snuffy, where's the thing again?
Pizza sushi.
Oh no.
We gotta make some pizza sushi.
Are you going straight for the gun, Matara?
Matara, Matara, please.
Please.
Okay.
I just won.
Oh my God, are you going straight for the gun?
Oh my God.
Alright, where is it?
Okay, just for protection.
I got the shank for protection.
Alright, let's see.
Where is it?
Where is the thing?
I found one of it.
Yeah, no, I found one of it.
But where's the other?
Where's the, like, activator?
What are you holding?
What the fuck is that?
You stay away from me.
What is that?
It's right.
I don't want to hurt anyone.
I tried to make you pizza sushi.
It would be a shame if you can't.
Oh.
Who is that?
Is that Rice?
Wait, what?
It's Navi and my...
Oh.
What the fuck?
There's always something.
There's always somebody.
I'm trying to find something important right now.
And I don't know where it is.
Is there a reason to keep going?
Because me too, buddy.
Yeah, it is.
It is.
It's a very good item that helps us win the game.
I'm trying to find it.
Where did it go?
Why did you try to hit me?
What the fuck?
Why did you try to slap me?
I literally just walked in and he tried to slap me.
Wait, she's dead.
Where is that one?
The killer.
It's Navi.
Slaps.
Where is it?
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Alright.
Nice.
We're almost there.
We need that one item.
Where is that?
Oh, wait.
What?
Wait.
Yeah, but we don't have the other piece of the puzzle.
I've been looking for it.
I know.
Me too.
I'm trying to find it too.
Where is it?
I need to find it.
I need to find it so I can blow her up before she realizes.
I'm trying to find a very important item that will help us win the game.
I'm trying to find.
I'm trying to find a very important item.
That will help us win the game.
There's no way!
I...
There's no one piece...
No one piece that will help us win!
Alright, somebody took an item Alright, somebody took an item that's very important.
She's going to be accidentally murdering the whole lobby.
That's sus!
And I turned around and I was like, did you just try to shoot me?
Wait!
Matara told me that you were... What?
Matara's innocent!
Why is she dead?
They're having some problems.
They'll be fine, I'm sure.
Rin, do you have anything in your inventory?
Do you have anything in your inventory?
No?
Okay.
Cause like, I'm... I'm trying to find this one item that's very important.
That'll help us win the game, but I can't find it.
It's a very... It's a secret... Wait!
How did she die?
She tries to shoot me through a screwdriver.
A screwdriver?
Bro, what the fuck?
You performed a lobotomy?
That's fucked!
You just performed a lobotomy without a license!
Oh my god!
I'm still trying to find this very important item.
Oh, you have to clean it.
It's black.
Wonderful.
It's the washing machine!
To the washing machine I go, I dare say.
I'll never find it.
Ah!
There, there, there!
There!
Right here.
You put it right here.
Okay.
One day I'll find this very important item.
I will not give up until I find this very important item.
I will not give up!
Oh, hey.
Where's my screwdriver?
Did I drop it?
Where the fuck did I put my screwdriver?
Wait a minute.
I was holding a screwdriver.
What the fuck happened?
Oh my god, where did I even put it?
Where did I put my screwdriver?
Screwdriver?
Where the fuck is the detonator?
Oh my god.
I can't find it!
I can't find anything!
These are all batteries.
Now there's no screwdrivers?
Okay.
I must find something.
It's so quiet.
I'm pretty sure all the traders are dead.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
They all have to be dead by now.
So it's just us completing tasks.
But we have eight minutes.
So I'm fine.
I'm not too worried.
I'm trying to find it.
I've been trying to find this fucking detonator for 20 years.
If you look closer than a quick glance, you'll find it.
But where?
I looked everywhere!
Oh, hey, screwdriver.
Okay.
At least I can do my task.
Everybody's trying to figure out...
Where is it?
All right, guys.
Where's the detonator?
Chat.
Chat, you guys know.
You guys have better eyes than me.
Wait, where was the...
Where was the vent that I saw earlier that needed to be vented?
What the fuck?
Oh, we're finished.
Nice.
Oh, it's pizza sushi time.
Okay.
God damn it.
It's where?
It has a chance to not spawn?
We just lost the 50...
Oh, my God.
We lost the 50-50.
It just doesn't spawn.
It literally doesn't.
Wait, what?
Is everything okay?
We're making pizza sushi.
Yay!
No, there's self-defense.
There's self-defense.
There's a self-defense.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Self-defense.
Look, look, look.
It's tuna.
It's self-defense.
Why fry tuna for one second?
Wait.
I'll do you tuna pizza.
Stay away from me.
Wait.
Press it.
Do it.
How do you clean a container?
Press one.
Press it.
Oh, wait.
No, that's a screwdriver.
I thought it was something else.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, come over here.
I want to show you something.
Oh, it's this.
We got to clean it.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then it was...
What was it?
This is cool rice.
That's not white rice.
That's cool rice.
That's a different color.
There's different colors of rice?
Oh, buddy.
Don't get me started.
There is...
Wait, how...
What?
This is why I don't do pizza sushi.
Wait, wait.
I'll show you something.
Jerry, come here.
Oh, buddy.
Oh, you're getting like...
You know, trust me.
Ev, there's...
Why don't you trust me?
Behind your eyes.
Why...
You...
What?
Something.
There's something wrong.
Why don't you trust me?
You should trust.
There's something wrong.
I'm really.
I'm looking for something.
Okay.
I can spell employee backwards.
You're a demon.
E-e-y-o-l-b-m-e.
I'm literally...
You get to spell employee backwards.
Sorry.
I'm rolling in circles.
Mom, are you wanted?
Spell employee backwards.
E-E-Y-O-L-P.
What do you mean?
Look at your top right.
What does your top right say?
It says employee.
Then you're a fucking idiot.
You're a fucking idiot.
That's amazing.
You can spell it backwards.
I have eyes.
Thank you.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, okay.
I'm over here.
Come over here.
I want to show you something.
You know what this is?
The bomb?
Yeah, pick it up.
Okay.
It doesn't work because there's no detonator.
Oh.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
But I can be a detonator.
If I can...
I'm innocent.
I'm an employee.
E-E-Y-O-L-P-M-E.
I just wanted to show her the C4.
Did you just spell employee the right way around?
Yeah.
It's because I'm just...
He's expelling checks.
Then you know I'm employee.
Then you know if I was a traitor, I wouldn't be able to spell it.
Spell it backwards.
E-E-Y-O-L-P-M-E.
Employee.
We did it.
I made a total mistake.
Wait.
Don't you...
Did the C4 kill me or did you shoot me in the back?
I shot you in the back.
I made it.
I wanted you to think...
You're evil.
Evil.
I wanted you to think it was the C4.
She thought it was the C4.
Guys!
Wait.
Who was the traitor?
So, it was me.
And my very first kill, I took the gun out.
And instead, I wanted to shoot...
I think I was trying to shoot you.
I... I... I pointed it at your back.
And instead of getting fired, I threw it over your shoulder.
Oh, that's really nothing.
I saw the gun come out and then she shot you.
Wait.
Then how did you die?
And then she picked it up and she went blind.
And I couldn't tell.
It was an excuse.
Something was sticking in my eye.
And then she shot me.
Wait.
How did you die though?
I didn't...
Shoot me then!
Snoopy!
Snoopy, why?
The person I tried to shoot picked it up and went...
What the...
Alright.
Alright, guys.
You guys want to do LG?
LG?
Last game.
Everybody.
Last game, everybody.
Last game.
Okay.
We can do this.
Last game.
Alright.
Let me see.
We can...
I believe in us.
GG.
Good luck, everybody.
Last game.
Glad we figured...
I've been employee every game.
I've got it like 500 times.
She...
Poor pass.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
Four tasks.
Pressure is one of them.
Pressure.
Alright.
I will find the thing.
I will find it.
It's nothing.
We have to find the thing.
We won these.
Okay.
We win these.
That's it.
We won these!
Oh, hey.
Okay, we gotta get that for protection.
I don't trust nobody.
Oh wait, the shotgun's better actually.
Wait.
Let's just grab two.
Okay.
Yeah, but where is the...
Wait, did you...
Put it in the scanner.
Put it in the scanner because they have to do scanner.
What?
Put it in the scanner because they have to do the scanner.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what is that?
Is it this room or this?
No, no, wait.
Computers.
Wait, wait.
No, actually.
No, put it in the pressure room.
Put it in the pressure room.
While they're figuring out the pressure.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna do it really subtly.
Really subtly.
Oh my god.
No, okay.
I'm trying to find an...
Oh, hey.
I'm an employee.
E-E-Y.
Y-O-L-M-E.
Employee.
What?
I spelled it correctly.
E-E-Y-O-L-M-E.
What?
Hello?
She misspelled employee.
I swear to god she misspelled employee.
I stopped.
I stumbled.
You're in trouble.
I stumbled one time.
I stop.
I do.
She misspelled.
I...
I spelled it right once.
She actually misspelled employee.
I saw...
I just stumbled because I don't do well in the pressure.
I was getting chased.
I lost.
That's not fair!
I was getting chased!
I thought I was gonna die!
And I didn't die!
There's no dead in here!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I misspelled it one time!
One time!
Oh my god!
Did the detonator not... Did the detonator not spawn in again?
It's just guns!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god!
The detonator has not spawned in yet again!
That's actually crazy!
I can't believe it!
The most fun weapon hasn't spawned in again!
I didn't want to kill it right away!
I should've.
I fucking should've.
The world's deadliest spelling bee.
That's life or death.
That spelling bee is life.
That's literally life or death.
Stop!
No!
Help!
Stop!
What?
Make sushi.
What the fuck's going on?
With my dying breath, I screamed, it's Bao.
And then immediately after I died, everyone went...
Wait, is it Bao?
I was spelling out employee, but I was getting chased by Mataya, and then she like...
That's a spelling mistake.
And then she killed me, cause I was... I was so stressed out.
I'm so glad no one asked me that, cause I'm dyslexic as hell.
Yes!
The evil has been defeated!
You know I'm illiterate, Mataya!
I got 99% correct!
That's like a pass!
No!
That's a pass!
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
99% is a pass.
I'm so sorry.
You look so sad, Green.
Green got killed by... Green got killed by Bao, and she screamed, Bao, but no one believed it.
With my dying breath, I screamed, it's Bao!
Immediately after I died, I heard, could it be Bao?
Is it Bao, you think?
Is it Bao?
I could be a complete piece of luck right now, but I'm just gonna...
All I had was a screwdriver and a dream.
A dream.
I'm souru classe.
Oh, is this a dream I have?
This ether is so stupid.
Like...
I'mston.
I understand this is Class 6, so you gotta actually click the point.
It's a cheat.
You're gonna look forward to it after this one.
I did not see it happening...
I was like...
Hello, um...
No.
No, no, it can't be her.
It's a bow as she stands next to a dead body?
Oh, there's one more!
They're gonna win this!
Wait!
Let's go!
They're gonna do it!
No, it's one killer.
I said it's a one cause two was just too many.
Oh wait, they're doing it!
Wait guys, we're gonna win our second employee game!
I don't remember.
What do we do with that?
Oh, they're just trying to figure out.
They don't know what to do.
Get a new battery!
Snuffy just ran off alone.
I hope that's not the last time we see her.
Oh dear.
We'll find out.
I have a different battery!
Oh, okay.
This is it.
Wait, are these both dead?
No, they're the same.
She put the same battery in!
She put the same...
Are we dead or are we misunderstanding the plot?
Yay!
We did it!
We won!
I'm so proud of all of us guys.
It only took us two hours to figure out the task.
Yeah!
Two hours!
Guys!
Even though we're chronically online, if we have two hours, we can survive on an abandoned island.
Yay!
Yeah, yeah.
I'm so proud of all of us.
That was fun!
Thank you everybody for joining!
Yay!
Thank you!
Thank you everybody!
Yipee!
Yay!
Thank you everybody for coming to the collab!
You guys had fun!
Bye everybody!
Bye bye!
I can't leave!
How do I get out?
You just quit.
I just leave.
Leave the lobby.
Goodbye guys!
Have fun with your streams and your days!
You are so good at tasks.
Yeah, she is.
I need you on like any teamwork team.
Any team that requires thinking.
This is great, my ego.
Thank you.
You for shooting.
You for thinking.
No, you're the shooter.
You shoot without reason.
You don't ask questions.
I hesitate.
You don't.
I'm like, could she?
Should I do it?
But you're like, no.
Bye guys!
Thanks for inviting me.
Thanks for subbing, Indrin!
I really appreciate it.
We had a great time.
Thank you for having me.
I have no idea how I got here, but I appreciate it.
Yeah, I hope it was okay.
I know it was a little bit overwhelming.
But I hope you still had fun.
But you know what?
I hope you had a great day.
I'll see you later.
Bye!
Thank you very much.
I will see you.
Once I figure out how the...
Oh, it's the Quit Lobby.
Bye bye.
Alright, that's fun!
I actually had a great time with all the ladies today.
It was very chaotic in the beginning.
But we started getting to know each other.
And everybody started figuring out how to play the game.
The biggest issue was that we were just like, how do you play this game?
How do you do the task?
Like, seven plus VTubers trying to figure out one task.
But I had a great time.
It was honestly very fun.
Very fun playing this game.
I'm happy with the group we got in the end.
And it was very chaotic.
It was very chaotic in the beginning.
But we slowly got...
We slowly listened to everybody and figured the game out very slowly.
But we still figured out the game.
How many VTubers does it take to change a generator?
Just like...
Lime and Reddit.
Seven VTubers and one...
No, it's one brain cell between all of us.
That's for sure.
But I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time watching as well.
And you enjoyed everybody's company.
I hope it was okay.
I didn't have any of the...
I hope you guys were able to figure out who's who.
If not, just enjoy the colors.
Enjoy the colors of everybody's because I know it might have been a bit disorienting trying to figure out who's who.
Who's talking and everybody.
But since we're using in-game voice chat, it wouldn't matter.
I use Discord overlays and stuff.
Since you guys won't even be able to see it.
So, I still hope you guys were able to figure out who's who.
Anyway, I'm going to rest here a little bit.
My voice is slowly dying.
So, I'm going to rest my voice before the second stream tonight.
I do have a second stream tonight.
I have a Goodnight Dragoons where I'm just going to hang out and chat with everybody.
So, I'm going to call it here, everyone.
I hope you guys check out all the VTubers, all the streamers that were playing with us today.
And I hope that you had a great time watching.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, stay up a little longer for the second stream.
I'm going to make the waiting room the moment the stream is over.
Anyway, a huge shout-out again to all the ladies that joined us today.
We had... let me just make sure I read it off so I don't miss anybody.
We had... make sure you check them out.
We had Amelie, Bao, me, Juniper, Lamu, Matara, Rin, and Snuffy.
So, please check them out.
Anyway, I'll see you guys later.
Bye-bye!